it is time for hatred mail what is
hatred mail this is hatred mail because
it's time to make America hate again
Patriot mail written by Patriots who
hate David Pakman because America and
because Freedom
this makes hatred mail unlike some but
like some others doesn't really need an
introduction
it is rife with some of the worst
actually grammar and spelling we've ever
seen which says a lot when it comes to
hatred mail and also really bad
arguments that aren't even really
arguments they're just that homonyms
take a listen you're a fool
so is your show you're another loser who
is Gale Lewis of this wealthy man Trump
and the power he has now go back to your
room and stay there till I say you can
come out you child David Pakman go play
your video game Pakman cut other Pakman
garbage presentation this is a Jew
communist propaganda the David Pakman
show
Jew communist propaganda my favorite
thing is saying I am jealous of Trump
with the IE rather than a J not that
that's the only misspelling relative to
jealous but I am completely Gallo's of
Trump I'm willing to excuse the you're
spelt you are absolutely there are two
different spellings of your and
sometimes the hatreds will get confused
sure and you are I think works well for
both of them but there's no explanation
for jealous like you keep can't you know
explain that away you've never been
jealous of the alpha male Pat no I mean
it sounds like maybe you could pronounce
that jealous but then it would be more
like jelly like not the actual word that
we know for jealous exactly and of
course gelatin not vegetarian certainly
not vegan and that would not be
tolerated by producer Pat no matter who
the hate reott thinks they are so I
think on all in all ways and in every
way this is one of the best hatred males
we've ever had and to celebrate that we
are offering you the coupon code hey
tree at 40 if you go to WWE pakman.com
you pick any membership doesn't matter
which one you realize it's time to
support the David Pakman show I'm gonna
counter
the hate and the hatreds by becoming a
member if you type in the coupon code
hey tree at 40 you save 40% and 115 hey
tree it's cry and that is a really great
thing for progressive media